je connais pas de marque qui soit aussi
complexe que xiaomi au niveau de ses
gammes je sais pas si vous avez déjà
fait l'expérience d'acheter un
smartphone de chez eux mais on parle
vraiment d'expérience c'est compliqué
c'est compliqué tellement les gammes
sont larges à moins que vous sachiez
exactement quel modèle est fait pour
vous et bien je vous mets au défi de
vous y retrouver dans cette grande gamme
tellement qu'elle est complexe tellement
qu'elle fournit tellement elle est
compliquée en fin d'exercice très simple
aujourd'hui on va venir éclaircies royal
et à coups de hache pour comprendre
comment ça marche au niveau de ses
gammes de shiomi parce que vraiment de
vous à moi c'est complètement
quand je tourne cette vidéo tout de
suite on est début janvier 2022 autant
vous dire que la gamme de 2022 n'a pas
encore commencé à sortir les
connaissances y ait omis je sais quelle
bête très grande très complexe avec
probablement deux nouvelles références
donc là on s'arrête sur ce qu'on
connaisse à dire tous les produits qui
sont arrivées jusqu'à fin 2021 regardez
déjà je vous montre directement sur mon
ordi à quel point c'est compliqué tel
moyen de produits vous avez cette gamme
me alors elle change de nom mais vous
expliquer ça tout à l'heure vous avez le
11 les pros vous avez long c'était le 11
light leumi 11e' le ultra on a de la 5g
on a de la 4g on a dû me not enfin bref
c'est un bordel absolue continue avec
rémy raid me 10,9 ses notes hui 2021
note 10 5 g bref on n'y comprend rien on
y comprend absolument rien il ya des
ssiad cia du nfc de tous les côtés je ne
sais pas du tout que ça correspond à moi
je sais mais peut-être pas vous ensuite
vous avez dû poko von haller tient là
c'est marrant parce que l'ag du f3 l'ag
du mx3 promet quand je vais en eau sur
coco et les regards des surprises hop là
bas non mamie de choses on va regarder
quand même surprise j'ai dû f3 du x3
produit 3 du x3 fc du f2 progresser le
bordel c'est le bordel 6,1 millions rien
qu'au regard est tout de suite commandé
grossir tout ça et on fait quoi on prend
une feuille mais il faut prendre à
gauche bon on va essayer d'être hyper
pragmatique et de faire simple on va se
regarder donc différentes gammes alors
déjà vous avez ce qu'on va appeler le
haut de gamme et ben ouais ce qu'ils
sont comme tout le monde ils ont
différentes gammes il ya du haut de
gamme ya du milieu de gamme il ya du bas
de gamme ya des gammes de tous les côtés
y en a beaucoup chez eux on a les hauts
de gamme dans le haut de gamme on a
plusieurs références et le premier truc
à savoir est que jusqu'à présent les
autres gars qui s'appelait mis quelque
chose a eu le million et demi dix neuf
et compagnie ça change le nom me a été
supprimé aujourd'hui on va parler de
xiaomi on va parler du chien on ose t on
auprès du chiot midouze qui va être
présenté bientôt à l'heure à laquelle je
fais cette vidéo je suis au 1012 tf1
bresse et compagnie donc on a ici dans
le haut de gamme dans le haut de gamme
il faut différencier plusieurs gammes
déjà on va avoir le modèle qu'on va
appeler le ultra alors l'ultra c'est le
plus haut de gamme on l'a eu pour la
première fois avec le mit aux ultras je
voulais présenter c'est un produit qui
était vachement même entendre ce qui se
faisait de mieux le top du top sobel le
haut du plafond c'est de très très très
très haut de gamme ensuite vous avez le
modèle professionnel qu'on n'a pas eue
en france l'année dernière mais qu'on a
eue il ya deux ans mais est sorti
l'année dernière on chine bravoure et
c'est déjà un peu le bazar au niveau des
sorties donc ces deux modèles là vont
constituer ce qu'on appellera l'ultra
haut de gamme voilà l'ultra hd j'ai pour
haut de gamme vous m'en voulez pas sera
plus simple comme ça ensuite vous allez
avoir d'autres appellations on va avoir
ce qu'on appellera le modèle normal ok
jusque là vous me sujet il n'y a pas de
soucis savait ce qu'on appelait avant le
million ce qu'on appellera le xiaomi 12c
modèle standard le modèle normal mais
ici par contre on reste dans du haut de
gamme dont du très haut de gamme
d'ailleurs parce que autant ici vous
êtes dans l'ultra haut de gamme
lorsqu'on va rester dans ce qu'on
appellera le très haut de gamme à il ya
plusieurs segmentation il ya le haut de
gamme il ya le très haut de gamme il ya
l'ultra haut de gamme bien trop du haut
de gamme et y en a tellement qu'il faut
le dire ensuite on va continuer un plat
avec le modèle qu'on va appeler le à
savoir ben lemouchia ou millions n'a eu
qu'à les derniers on a eu le million ici
on a eu le chien ont mis onze c'est
inouï n'y a pas eu depuis l'annoncé déjà
même là je sais depuis que c'est dire
donc là on va voir votre normal c'est ce
qu'on va appeler du très haut de gamme
dès qu'on arrive à partir du 8 on est
dans le milieu haut de gamme à la voix
la note bordel ici donc là ça va être du
milieu haut de gamme voyez on fait les
gars on descend et ensuite toujours dans
cette gamme shiomi on va avoir le modèle
qu'on va appeler light et oui là le
light ici c'est du milieu de gamme donc
ça déjà il faut le connaître pour les
gammes xiaomi vous avez donc quand on
vous parle du chien au 1012 est bien
chez au 1012 jomy 12 pro sur mes douze
ultra sûre midouze issho midouze light
donc il faut vraiment avoir cette vision
globale de cette gamme xiaomi ancien
membre comprendre comment ça marche donc
là vous avez modèles très haut de gamme
de l'ultra haut de gamme du milieu haut
de gamme et ensuite milieu de gamme
alors ça c'est la gamme chiot mais
maintenant il ya la gamme chez comité et
ben ouais on est là pour se marrer quand
même alors ensuite le chien au mythe et
ça va être toujours du haut de gamme
donc on est vraiment dans le haut de
gamme mais c'est une gamme qui est un
papa parce qu'elle sort six mois après
donc avec quelques technologies qui ont
évolué il ya quelques choix qui ont été
faits autant ici on est donc l'ensemble
du très haut de gamme autant les dents
du haut de gamme on est un peu moins ce
pays qu'ils ont fait le choix de
supprimer deux trois petits trucs
histoire de vous proposer un produit qui
va être un peu moins cher céline ici
vous allez avoir alors la regarder le
reste des petits points pour vraiment
comprendre que ont des six mois après
vous allez avoir le tpr oh oui ça c'est
le plus haut de gamme de cette gamme est
en tout cas en suisse c'est sympa est
schizophrénique quand je dis ça comme ça
ensuite vous avez le thé normal comme on
a eu le xiaomi on se tiendra le 12 t qui
doit arriver dans cette deuxième partie
d'année et puis ensuite vous avez le thé
light mais connaissant chiyo me on
pourrait voir arriver un té i 1 t il
très doux tout est possible tout est
toujours possible chez eux alors ici
comment est-ce qu'on voit ça sur le t on
est dans du haut de gamme là on est sur
le pro dans l'idée d'un smartphone qui
va être entre du très haut de gamme et
du haut de gamme s'est pas réellement du
très haut de gamme comme on peut avoir
ici sur un million ce pro donc il ya
quand même une différence vous disons dû
faire quelques choix oubliez pas que la
gamme t c'est une gamme moins cher même
si elle est haut de gamme elle est moins
spectaculaire gamme shiomi standard donc
là on a trois référents ok c'est un peu
plus simple et puis ensuite lorsque vous
êtes dans le des light vous êtes ici sur
du milieu de gamme ah là là c'est pas
très compliqué mais on sera sur un
milieu de gamme qui sera moins spéculer
light de la gamme shiomi comprenez on
est un peu en dessous en fait si vous
regardez par exemple un chiot me normale
avec un chiot me tais et bien le normal
sera plus payé que le thé et le light
sera plus payé que le thé light fait que
ça marche là on est un cran en dessous
donc ça c'est pour le haut de gamme ok
jusqu'à là c'est facile ensuite on va
avoir une gamme qui va être entrée
milieu de gamme plus axé milieu de gamme
et cette gamme ça va être la gamme
renlin shi jun marque red me nots ça
c'est l'entrée milieu de gamme parce que
vous avez sur des tarifs aux alentours
de 150 euros 200 euros jusqu'à 300 euros
300 euros c'est du milieu de gamme alors
comment ça se passe et le produit le
plus haut de gamme de la gamme rémy note
c'est leur ennemi notes pro donc lui ça
va être le produit plus milieu regarde
vraiment dans du milieu de gamme ici
alors hop milieu de gamme voilà mon
petit lapin là on est plus en tour de
250 300 euros ensuite il va ya voir
leurs ennemis note modèle tout simple le
modèle un peu standard leurs ennemis
note on est à l'entrée du milieu de
gamme donc c'est pareil on va être dans
milliers de gamme mais un peu moins
spéculer réellement on sera un peu moins
bons en photo et un processeur un peu
moins performant ensuite y avait le
renmin note avec un thé sauf que celui
là il n'y a pas été présenté à une
dernière donc on va se dire qu'en
l'oubli allez hop on le supprime aux
oubliettes ça fait déjà un mois et ça
c'est bien et ensuite on va avoir leur
et demi note avec un ace lui il est
beaucoup plus bas dans la gamme là on va
situé dans l'entrée de gamme c'est pas
de l'entrée entrée entrée de gamme mais
c'est quand même malgré tout de l'entrée
de 4 ou de l'entrée du milieu de gamme
si vous voulez pas ce qu'on va voir
l'entrée de gamme mais va y avoir milieu
de gamme d'un milieu de gamme il va y
avoir le haut de gamme du milieu de
gamme et l'entrée de gamme du milieu de
gamme j'ai compris l'histoire donc ici
avec leurs ennemis notre pro et bien on
est dans le haut de gamme du milieu de
gamme avec leurs ennemis note on est
dans le milieu de gamme du milieu de
gamme et avec le rémi notait son nez
dans l'entré deux guerres du milieu de
gamme mais on reste dans le milieu de
gamme voilà l'idée et ben oui faut pas
s'arrêter là vous avez la gamme et demi
alors la guerre et demi elle est aussi
sympathique parce que elle c'est de
l'entrée de gamme et où il devrait
entrer de bien pour le coup donc on va
pas passer des heures dessus parce que
c'est pas forcément smartphones que vous
vous allez acheter ce fait le smartphone
pour les primo accédants ce tour leur
tout premier smartphone qu'on va être
dans une gamme aller qu'est ce que je
vous avez noté dans une gamme de 99 à
150 euros ici donc ici vous allez avoir
du raid mais vous allez avoir du ray
nice et vous allez avoir du rewmi cnfc
ben oui ajoute des noms vous avez du
raid unité je m'applique même plus
tellement j'en peux plus vous avez dur
et demi à bref vous avez une gamme qui
va aller à peu près de 20 euros en 20
euros tous les 20 euros vous allez
retrouver une petite différence une
caméra qui ont un peu plus 2 mégapixels
un processeur un poil plus performant
mais ici c'est pas un truc de dingue qui
vous êtes et reste ensuite c'est la
gamme locaux alors on l'appelait bocaux
phone mais c'est la gamme poko alors ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que dans
d'autres régions du monde shiomi et poko
sont des marques indépendantes donc
elles vont pas être bosser ensemble sauf
qu'ici en france et bien xiaomi poko
c'est la même chose donc on va se parler
ici de poko phone est ici c'est beaucoup
plus sain pour une fois bravo chiottes
alors regardez je vais avoir en plus
c'est le pot coeff rossa c'est le plus
haut de gamme ensuite vous avez le pot
coeff tout court donc avec ces deux
modèles là vous êtes chez coco dans le
haut de gamme du milieu de gamme hélas
oui parce que pour cause ça reste quand
même du milieu de gamme du milieu de
gamme qui est vraiment axé performances
sont pas des smartphones vous allez
faire de belles photos avec donc si vous
cherchez un photophone offert de belles
images il fouille dans la gamme mieux
dans la game it est clairement pas aller
dans la gamme peau que vous pourrez
faire des choses sympas mais c'est pas
tout le plus dingue du monde ensuite
vous dans la gamme beaucoup x là vous
êtes dans le milieu de gamme du milieu
de gamme la gamme poko donc vous avez un
modèle pro vous avez un modèle aussi
standard lui poko x donc ça c'est du
milieu de gamme vient pas mon petit
lapin ça c'est fait ça écrit et puis
ensuite vous avez tout en bas de la
feuille lepoko m et le poème c'est
l'entrée de gamme chez coco comme ça au
moins il n'y a pas de surprise vous
voyez la lisibilité c'est beaucoup plus
facile ici pour l'instant parce qu'ils
ont souvent tendance à complexifier un
peu les choses fc le haut de gamme chez
poko xc le milieu de gamme et mc
l'entrée de gamme vous êtes chez poko
smartphone dédié gaming performance boy
clairement et ça marche bien et ça s'est
très très bien donc voilà un peu ce
qu'il en est et voyez donc si vous
voulez des smartphone orienté photo
orienté performances orientées recharge
avec ce qui se fait de mieux chez xiaomi
et bien on va tout de suite dans la
gamme shiomi chez home et 12 et toutes
les déclinaisons je vous ai présenté ici
la gamme t elle est aussi très bonne en
terme de photos osées de la performance
vous êtes quand même moins spectre on va
aller moins loin quelques compromis qui
ont été faits ensuite si vous avez un
petit peu moins de budget entre 150 et
200 à 300 euros et bienvenue sur la
guerre et demi note la gare et demi en
entrée de gamme et ensuite la gamme pogo
phone pour la performance brute voilà
pour cette gamme j'espère que ça vous
aura aidé parce que c'est vrai que c'est
très très compliqué chez shiomi et là
encore au moment où je vous parle je
voulais dit mais sur la gamme de 2021
ici voilà gamme de 2022 qui va arriver
mais soyez rassurés ans que même s'ils
changent les noms même s'il apporte de
nouvelles dénominations aurait sur la
même structure avec l'ultra haut de
gamme le très haut de gamme le haut de
gamme et puis ensuite du milieu de gamme
avec le modèle lights et c'est pareil
pour l'été c'est la même structure un
peu moins ce pays qu'est il se peut
qu'une nouvelle dénomination dans le
rémi note ça sera la même idée c'est un
âne idées partout on en reparlera sûr
mais on en parlera beaucoup parce qu'il
ya plein de nouveaux produits j'ai hâte
de tester le che aux méduses qui était
annoncé au mois de décembre lors de la
présentation de qualcomm du snapdragon 8
john wayne j'ai hâte de voir ce qu'ils
nous ont fait en terme de nouveauté
serait extrêmement intéressant abonnez
vous pas déjà fait comme ça vous saurez
tout le petit bouton rouge et là si les
rouches et vous n'êtes pas abonné vous
cliquez sur la cloche pour a notifié et
nous paie aucune vidéo d'ici là nous
embrasse pour le soin de vous d'amour et
à bientôt débile au chaos
[Musique]
et